thank you
it's 10 o'clock this is Sky News at 10
our top story
World Athletics bans transgender
athletes from all women's competition
the decision that the Council made is a
primarily principled based decision and
that is the overarching need to protect
the female category
interest rates rise from four percent to
four and a quarter percent after an
unexpected rise in inflation but the
bank of England says the economy is
performing better than expected
mortgages loans and credit cards could
become more expensive while Savers will
see greater returns
also tonight Tick Tock is not an agent
of China the social media Boss faces
hours of tough questions by the U.S
Congress
a city split by War we have a special
report from Taz in Yemen
the end of that road is where the
fighting is no man's land and dozens of
families are living in this area
trafficked for his organs a Nigerian
Senator and his wife are found guilty
under the modern slavery act for
conspiring to traffic a man to the UK
[Applause]
violence erupts between police and
protesters in Paris after National
strikes grind France to a halt
has it or there's no such thing as
Society but there is such a thing as a
party my idea
and the iconic British satire spitting
image gets its West End debut we speak
to the creators
plus we'll take a first look at
tomorrow's front pages in our press
preview from half past
[Music]
foreign
good evening the president of world
Athletics Lord Co has told Sky News
tonight that the organization's decision
to exclude transgender women from female
competitions is to protect women in the
sport the ban will include male to
female transgender athletes who have
been through male puberty but it's a
decision that could divide opinion and
the question now is if other sports
follow suit our sport correspondent Rob
Harris reports
they're ideal is Sport inclusive for all
but how to balance that with fairness
and sporting Integrity the word
Athletics it means no transgender women
being allowed in female events the
decision was taken in consultation with
a number of stakeholders including 40
member federations
our coaches our athletes and through the
athletes commission as well as a range
of other community groups including
trans groups un experts the
international Olympic Committee and para
Athletics there are athletes now who
will feel excluded and discriminated
against what is your message to them as
they feel
this pain perhaps that the decision that
the Council made is a primarily
principled based decision and that is
the overarching need to protect the
female category this is what our sport
is here to do uh and I think the council
has done that today this ruling only
covers world ranking events and World
Athletics says there are no transgender
female athletes currently in
international competitions who've been
through male puberty but the impact of
the decision resonates Beyond sport as a
population group trans women are not a
threat to women's sport trans women are
still hugely underrepresented uh across
all levels of women's sport it is true
that trans women maintain some physical
advantages over CIS women but these
advantages have not led to
overrepresentation World Athletics had
initially preferred basing entry to the
female category on blood testosterone
levels for Trans athletes But ultimately
there was no widespread support for that
also rejected was having a new open
category that did find backing at this
track where hopeful's dream of competing
at the 2024 Paris Olympics as we know
the men's times are so much faster than
female times so I think
um already you kind of know that they
would have some sort of physiological
advantage over the female athletes and
so I do think it would be better to have
an open category and become inclusive as
to have no category at all this is a
landmark ruling for sports a tougher
decision than anticipated ultimately
World Athletics has followed swimming
and rugby in deciding only those female
at Birth can compete in women's events
other sports including football are
still reviewing their transgender
eligibility policies
World Athletics will continue to consult
transgender athletes and could review
its decision but for now ensuring an
unfair sporting Advantage is not gained
has been prioritized over inclusion
I'm pleased to say Rob Paris is here in
the studio for me now
um Lord Co has said that it's not no
forever uh it could be reviewed
ultimately but what does it mean for now
well for now it means that no trans
women can compete in these top level
events but there are no known trans
women competing at the top level in
athletics and that is why some of the
reaction tonight from across the world
is questioning why this policy has come
in because transgender people can feel
amongst the most marginalized and
discriminated against in society and
here they are facing discrimination in
sport should be a Pastime it should be a
way of enjoying themselves but now this
is a sport deciding actually there is no
place for transgender women who've gone
through male puberty to compete at the
top level and the reason why is because
they think actually they could well be a
competitive Advantage gain despite the
plans that were on the table to allow
transgender women to compete if
testosterone levels were lowered and
that certainly is the way other sports
have gone such as weightlifting and it
was two years ago at the Tokyo Olympics
that for the first time a transgender
woman Laura Hubbard did compete in the
weightlifting but for now the focus will
become on other sports particularly the
likes of football and Athletics will
have to deal with this decision that is
one of the most significant for the
biggest Sports at an Olympics yeah isn't
it just all right Rob thank you very
much indeed
now the bank of England raised interest
rates from four percent to four and a
quarter percent today it is the 11th
rate rise in a row increasing from point
one percent that was back in December
2021. the chancellor Jeremy Hunt has
said that he hopes that will get a grip
on inflation which jumped unexpected
unexpectedly to 10.4 percent last month
but with a volatile global banking
sector industry experts are concerned
about what it could mean for the
financial system our economics and data
editor Ed Conway has been looking at
what it could mean for you
if you think you're still having a
mortgage right now how about having 36
mortgages
for Sean a landlord in Hull a single
interest rate hike means 36 or eight
hikes our costs have increased
from about six thousand five hundred to
seventeen thousand five hundred in the
space of 14-month sites it's a massive
difference so we know we're going to
have to put rents we are putting rents
up we're having to put rents up
reluctantly with today's increase we're
breaking even on some Properties or even
in a deficit in minus it's um it's it's
really bad news
it's a useful reminder that higher
interest rates aren't just a big deal
for those with mortgages those costs
filter through the system and often get
passed on to renters too
but there was actually good news from
the bank today alongside the rate
increase it now believes Britain will
narrowly avoid falling into recession
this year back at the beginning of
February yeah we were really a bit on a
knife edge as to whether there would be
a recession certainly we thought the
economy would be quite stagnant I'm not
saying it's going to it's not Off to the
Races let's be clear but I'm a bit more
optimistic now but many economists warn
that the bank will have to do more to
clamp down on Rising prices I certainly
wouldn't
um rule out them going up towards five
percent
um but I think the MPC have done most of
the heavy lifting that they need to do
so they've raised interest rates from
nearly zero to four and a quarter
percent now and maybe they need to go up
to perhaps closer to five percent but
the bank is walking a dangerous
tightrope now one of the bank of
England's main jobs is trying to keep
inflation under control it's supposed to
be hitting two percent but as you can
see it's way above that 10.4 in February
and that helps explain why it is Raising
interest rates 11 straight increases up
to four point two five percent now but
here's the issue the higher that goes
the more the risk of financial
instability and you have problems in
Banks leading to a dilemma for the bank
of England does it want to clamp down on
inflation or does it want to keep
markets calm
investors still think there'll be
another one or two rate risers to come
but with banks having collapsed on both
sides of the Atlantic
many are asking whether there are still
more financial time bombs yet to go off
at Conway Sky News
now the UK Parliament has today blocked
Tick Tock from being used on the estate
Wi-Fi citing National Security concerns
it comes as the chief executive of the
Chinese owned social media firm face the
U.S Congress it's chair calling Tick
Tock a weapon from the Chinese Communist
Party Skies Science and Technology
editor Tom Clark reports
is America's security threatened by Tick
Tock its CEO arrived at Congress
prepared to reassure lawmakers the U.S
and his platform's 150 million users
there could trust them there are many
misconceptions about our company and I'm
very proud to come here and represent
them and all our users here in this
country
but the committee's Mind seemed made up
to the American people watching today
hear this Tick Tock is a weapon by the
Chinese Communist party to spy on you
manipulate what you see and exploit for
future Generations Mr Chu trudge
dismissed any connection between Tick
Tock its parent company bite dance and
the Chinese Communist Party a
congressman since I've been CEO of this
company I have not had any discussions
with Chinese government officials
and answer criticism of how Tick Tock
fails to protect young users from
harmful content the potential security
privacy content manipulation concerns
raised about tech talk are really not
unique to us the same issues to apply to
other companies Mr Chew tried to argue
Tick-Tock was promising to go further
than any social media company to protect
users data and safety but the committee
weren't buying it
you damn well know that you cannot
protect the data and security of this
committee or the 150 million users of
your app because it is an extension of
the CCP and with that I yield back can I
respond sure
no we're gonna move on
even critics of tick tock found it hard
to watch this is something that they
they can't win they complicate those
really sort of angry anti-china Hawks
they can't placate those who are kind of
uh letting go of 20 years of anger at
Big Tech and the realization that we let
these companies writ large get too big
and uh couldn't control them as the
grilling continued in DC parliament in
London announced the app would be
blocked from Wi-Fi on its estate our
bans on Tick Tock a sensible step as
diplomatic relations deteriorate or an
erosion of freedoms more commonly seen
in States like China Tom Clark Sky News
well to Yemen now where people have been
living in Conflict since 2014.
in 2020 the United Nations said that at
least 227
000 people had died due to the war
most of those deaths are from the
indirect consequences of conflict famine
the outbreak of disease like cholera
under lack of Health infrastructure
it's being fought between the Shia
houthi insurgents with links to Iran who
control parts of the west of the country
including Capital Sana and the former
Sunni government backed by a saudi-led
coalition which includes the U.S and UK
the city Towers is split into two the
houthi control one-half government
troops the other and Skye's special
correspondent Alex Crawford and her team
are the first International journalists
in Yemen since a Saudi Iran agreement
re-established diplomatic ties between
the two states the team are in the
country to investigate its impact and
here is their report
we're given a two-vehicle government
Army escort to head towards the besieged
city of Taz
it's been split in two for most of the
past eight years of war with most key
roads into and out blocked off by
fighting
it's meant to uniquely slow torture for
the Tas civilians with the houthi
militia held to one half of the City by
government troops who control the other
the city has been blasted to bits in
places with booby trap bombs buried in
gardens by the retreating Fighters and
mines hidden in kitchen ovens to blow up
any returning residents they've been
planted down Alleyways and left in the
piles of rubble and rubbish
The Siege has brought parts of Taz to
the brink of starvation yet families are
still living here
Muhammad chose us round the bombed out
shopping center which is now his home
his family is living in the basement
a lot of damage to every floor that
we've visited so far a lot of hits on
just this building alone
over there is one of the houthi bases
Muhammad tells us it's by the old
presidential Palace it's from there
snipers pick off civilians or fire
Rockets
three of Muhammad's children were born
in this Siege
they all show signs of malnutrition and
spend most of their lives inside
of course I worry about the Muhammad
says this isn't a safe place I don't let
them go outside on their own in case
there are Rockets or anything
neither children nor pensioners are safe
I was shot in the back by a sniper her
home's right on the front line and she
refuses to be pushed out
I refuse to leave my house she tells us
I refuse to the houthis would shout at
me crazy woman leave your house but I
will never ever leave the war has never
let up in Taz and whilst there's
increasing optimism about a negotiated
settlement for the country those hopes
seem to have halted at the gates of this
city
idea of how close they all are living to
the front line at the end of that road
is where the fighting is no man's land
and dozens of families are living in
this area they've had to put up sheets
to try and obscure the view of the
sniper who has positioned himself just
beyond there
it means constant exchanges between the
warring groups
we're defending our land and our
families one tells us
we want peace another says but they
don't want it they're killing innocent
people and children and that's why we
carry weapons
this intransigence has led to one of the
world's worst humanitarian disasters
with starvation poverty and disease in
the hospital Wards homes and streets of
Yemen
three-month-old ayard is holding on to
Life by a thread the youngest of six
who've all had the same battle to
survive in a country where her mother
has to choose between food or medicine
when she can pay for neither
give them anything my daughter was very
weak and we needed to take her to the
hospital she explains but we didn't have
the money so we had to wait to try to
get someone by then she was unconscious
those like Fatima want Justice too the
mother of nine knows more than most
about loss
they were kids not Fighters she's
talking about her children four of them
were blown up in one day three were
killed outright the fourth only a
toddler lost a leg
their mutilated bodies are all she's
left of her babies
praying for revenge for their violent
deaths
she's compiled a file with their details
and wants to track down those who fired
the mortar shell that killed them as
they were playing outside their home
nothing can ever replace my children she
says
they'll never come back look at these
pictures she keeps saying to us they're
just children
she's pregnant again but would have
aborted if doctors had agreed
she doesn't want to bring another child
into this war-torn place
she can't feed those she still has her
two-year-old Malik has sweet tea with
yesterday's bread it's her first and
only meal of the day Alex Crawford Sky
News and Taz City Yemen
a prominent Nigerian politician and his
wife have been found guilty for their
part in a plot to traffic a man to the
UK so that his kidney could be harvested
to help their sick daughter the case
marks the first time defendants have
been convicted under the modern slavery
Act of an organ harvesting conspiracy
Sadia Chaudhary reports
arriving at a police station far from
home
distressed a victim of modern slavery
his face in this photo is blurred he sat
next to the woman who was about to get
his kidney she the daughter of a wealthy
Nigerian politician
the senator his wife and a london-based
doctor were all found guilty today of
human trafficking for organ harvesting
modern slavery is all around us
we need the Public's help in identifying
potential victims of trafficking and
exploitation to bring offenders to
Justice and to protect the vulnerable
the aqua ahmadus found their victim here
in Lagos Nigeria a 21 year old Market
Trader they offered him seven thousand
pounds and a better life away from here
modern slavery it's really human
trafficking the victims do not have any
choice in the matter they cannot give
consent and they're coerced into selling
their bodies or their organs in this
particular way so I think the modern
slavery Act is exactly the right the
instrument for trying to tackle these
abusers it was doctors at this London
Hospital who'd refused to operate they
interviewed the victim and found him
unprepared for such a life-changing
procedure
in court we finally heard his side of
the story misled threatened he'd told
police the man said if you do not do it
here he would carry me back to Nigeria
and do it there in court Sonia
ekweremadu wept as the verdicts were
read out this has been a landmark case a
legal first of its kind here in the
United Kingdom the first time that
anyone has been convicted under the
modern slaveries Act of organ harvesting
eke ikoromadu his wife Beatrice and Dr
obina abetta are due to be sentenced in
May Saudia chaudry Sky News at the old
bayley in London
meanwhile police have fired tear gas in
Paris tonight where demonstrators have
protested for a ninth day against
changes to pensions and the retirement
age president Emmanuel macaws used
special powers to push the qualifying
age up by two years to 64. protesters
have gathered in cities across the
country blockading train stations
motorways refineries and ports thousands
have taken to the streets in Paris where
there has been major disruption Adele
Robinson is there and has sent this
report
this is a political crisis spilling onto
Parisian streets
as anger turned to violence
seriously look what they're doing this
man shouts
with a police force lacking patience and
accused of using unnecessary Force
a nationwide strike against Emmanuel
macron's plans to raise the retirement
age to 64 started off largely peacefully
but frustration over the president
pushing through reform without a vote
gave this March momentum and then chaos
symbol of this unrest taking a stand
against a president who's accused of
overruling the will of the people and it
shows no sign of abating
French citizens are questioning their
leaders Democratic legitimacy once is a
democracy but just now
we feel it's not really a democracy they
compare us to the people that attacked
the capital in the USA and I think that
it's absolutely uh disgusting
more protests will coincide with King
Charles visit in a few days a lavish
Versailles dinner likely scaled back
but macron's argument for reforms
economic insisting it will be law this
year
and Fanning the Flames of an
increasingly violent and radical protest
movement Adele Robinson Sky News Paris
well these are the latest pictures from
the southwest city of Bordeaux that is
where the historic City Hall has been
set on fire dramatic images there the
mayor said he was saddened by what he
calls an act of vandalism but fire
Services were able to contain that fire
now secure stoma has shared his tax
returns for the last full Financial year
he committed to publishing his tax
returns just a day after the Prime
Minister Rishi sunak had done the same
after a question from Skye's political
correspondent Liz Bates
now the prime minister's publishes I'll
published mine I hope to be able to do
that later on today so that's very very
straightforward
um I'm glad the Prime Minister has
published his tax returns
um I think that's the right thing to do
others will obviously analyze those
returns
the labor leader paid more than 67 000
pounds in tax for the year
2021-2022 starman's tax statement shows
that he made capital gains of more than
85 000 pounds in that Financial year on
which he paid
23 900 pounds in capital gains tax
the British Medical Association has
announced four more days of strikes by
Junior doctors in England overpay the
BMA said that its members will hold
industrial action from the 11th to the
14th of April it claims the government
is still refusing to make a credible
offer or any offer to resolve the
dispute
Gwyneth Paltrow is back in court for the
third day of a hearing following claims
that she recklessly crashed into Terry
Sanderson during a ski trip in Utah in
2016. his daughter Polly Sanderson
grasham has testified and described her
dad as a fun-loving gregarious man prior
to the incident she said he's now in a
really negative place
there was a time when he's sitting in a
chair by the by my window
in Idaho in Idaho and I I almost
expected drool to be coming out of his
mouth that was my first real kind of
slap in the face of like something's
terribly wrong
now the satirical comedy show spitting
image is going to transfer from the TV
screens to the stage this year the new
cast of characters will include the king
Harry and Megan Tom Cruise and Boris
Johnson our arts and entertainment
correspondent Katie Spencer has more
uh here I am at the front of house I
have no idea where the stage door is if
only someone had told me from facing MPS
over the party Gate scandal to slipping
past theatergoers at the stage door I I
didn't mean to come across at all as
misleading but Tom Cruise has said that
I can have dressing room one from now on
so I'd like my usual Rider please or the
champagne and uh girls Boris Johnson's
rubber doppelganger set to feature
alongside some rather familiar faces as
the satirical puppet show spitting image
comes to London's West End
it's the state of seeing these famous
people in in grotesque so this sort of
an amplified version of them kind of
saying the things you really want them
want to hear them saying the opposite of
unanimous is tired in its prime back in
the 80s 15 million viewers used to tune
in to watch spitting image
the former prime minister might just
have had a lucky Escape not featuring in
the show back then as during its 18
Seasons it was brutal in some of its
takedowns of course Society has changed
a lot since then well has it well
there's no such thing as Society but
there is such a thing as a party my idea
so in the age of online outrage where we
are perhaps more mindful about not
focusing on physical flaws is the show
still able to be as Savage
people want us to go way way further so
there are parts of the show that we've
made even more outrageous because the
public it's not the Coliseum people are
there and they just want to see they
want to see blood
while the former prime minister might
have a starring role in this stage show
ironically for Boris Johnson between the
partygate Scandal and the covert inquiry
this may well be the least controversial
of all the appearances he has to make
Katie Spencer Sky News
just a quick bit of sport to bring in
our England's Captain Harry Kane is now
the nation's all-time top men's goal
scorer that's after scoring his 54th
International goal in a 2-1 win over
Italy Kane scored from the penalty spot
just before half-time in a euro 2024
qualifier in Naples and has now
surpassed Wayne Rooney's record
and Northern Ireland got their campaign
off to a winning start beating at San
Marino to